[Musique]
un mongolien dans une famille c'est un
véritable défi jeté par la nature les
proches de janot à eux ont relevé un
défi par la sympathie et même par le
muhr au point que le pouzin janot michel
carmassi a tourné avec lui le film
bouleversant que vous allez voir un film
ou le cinéma joue pleinement son rôle de
communication et de rapprochement des
êtres je vous pose la question
ce sont des enfants évidemment dans le
cerveau est atteint quand une grosse
tête en général cette alfa romeo en plus
que les autres mont-joli et machines
type qu'istres pied qui il y a pas toute
sa lucidité
c'était quelque chose appelle ça une
grosse fête quoi
on
-
et
ce qu'on peut donner comme définition
c'est qu'un mongolien à un chromosome en
trop sur la paire va dire et cette
apparition d'un chromosome
supplémentaire va entraîner toute une
série de perturbations physiques et
l'apparence différentes moral et le
comportement est différent
psychologiques surtout car le
développement intellectuel va s'arrêter
à un certain stade
je n'aurai pas ma vie ce que mathilde à
venir ou et noja nom n'est pas mon fils
puisque c'est mon cousin germain
c'est un beau lien bien sûr et il est
venu avec moi parce que toute la vie je
m'en suis occupé
et puis alors quand sa mère n'a plus pu
s'occuper de lui il avait 40 ans à ce
moment là et il en a 54 maintenant je
les prie donc ça fait 14 ans que je les
salue il y aura quand même beaucoup
changé de choses dans mon existence du
moment que plus peu de lui est ce qu'un
homme au tournant maintenant on peut
dire que nous sommes parce que dans la
vie pratique et à la vie pratique non
non plus j'ai voulu essayer de le faire
raser voiliers mais lui tournera
toujours au même endroit toujours sur le
même coin
c'est comme pour le faire débarbouiller
ils affrontaient toujours du même côté
donc je préfère le faire ça fait que je
hais ce que pouvait laisser celle non le
laisser seul non ça je serais pas
tranquille je ne veux pas le laisser les
ventes pratiquement comme la commune et
jeunes eux mêmes
tu veux goûter café oui tu as bien
d'idées tu sais aujourd'hui oui allait
tourner le zoo vers 5 heures c'est
l'heure du goûter
alors là dieu garde s'il n'avait pas son
goûter ils seraient ils seraient perdus
il serait vraiment malheureux c'est
quelque chose qui fait partie de sa vie
bien sûr alors je lui donne du chocolat
foscao ton animal et lui alors le coni
malte est devenu totti matic et c'est un
vrai régal et toutes les fois qu'il est
en train de goûter ou de prendre son
repas
alors il se regarde à gauche l'épaule
gauche n'est pas le droite et il a
l'impression que chaque gorgée il a
grandi grossi parce que sans grand
bonheur c'est de venir gran efforts et
avant alors il c'était la voiture il
préférait la voiture et quand on lui
demande et ils disaient elles sont
rouges et c'est une ferrain villach y
retourner ou une matraque alors l'appel
à rire c'est une équipe ferrari bien sûr
et la matraque c'est la matra
[Musique]
et maintenant alors ils tombent et que
la voiture je trouve dangereux et c'est
pour ça qu'ils deux changé il veut
plutôt pas mal comme tu dis que c'est
trop dangereux laquelle elle aurait
vraiment eu maldonne offrir encore de
bons comme j'arrive comme ça vous savez
un an après
[Musique]
et
qu'est ce que c'est que tu prépares
janola et tous tes cahiers qu'est ce que
c'est que tu prépares voilà alors là ils
tous le jour il passe son temps à
gribouiller aeby qui passe une thèse de
doctorat qui passera au mois de juin
29e nous l'avons même 21 professeurs api
soi-disant milan voire se note est tout
heureux il reçoit des récompenses
silvert mois soit disant des cartes
postales qui le lui la remise de
récompenses celui dans le des notes et
jamais comme ça et là thèse est toujours
pour le mois de juin et chaque année ça
revient c'est pour le prochaine mois de
juin n'ont pas regagné le vison it as
pris ta moyens le professeur voilà qui
sait c'est la file bellemare avait dit
dans sa belle-mère un peu et shell sont
définis professeur lui sent bon drouet
ya un coup oui deux fois
au japon ces journées il n'est pas
secret bien il ne le dit pas dès qu'il
est levé le matin et qu'il est prêt quoi
ils installent il va installer tout
toutes ces affaires sur la table bien
rangée que cahier dépasse pas l'autre et
puis après voilà il écrit tout le jour
et sans se lasser
cet homme car il a 55 ans il a besoin de
ritualiser tout et de rythme et où il
est prisonnier du rythme et du rythme si
on lui enlève ça qu'il est perdu il lui
faut des semaines des mois pour en
trouver un autre
ces rythmes sont sa vie il ne vit pas ça
mais elle marche pas mais ça fait rien
elle a eu marché la force de la montée
elle a fini par pas par se défaire bien
sûr et tous les soirs 6 heures il me dit
je vais mettre ma montre dans la chambre
ça ces rituels et puis le lendemain il
la reprend ça bien avec toutes ces
affaires de thèse c'est chaque jour la
même chose sans se lasser
tous les jours c'est pareil du 1er
janvier la saint sylvestre et c'est
pareil pour le soir quand ils se
déshabillent ses habits sont rangés sur
le dossier de sa chaise quand même pas
pierre musique les deux sens dans le
parterre q ne dépasse pas plus d'un
centimètre l'autre par dessus tout ça il
met sa montre et chaque jour on
recommence au carré si quelqu'un est
touché alors qu'il ne dormirait pas il a
besoin de points de repères il a besoin
de béquilles qui restent à leur place ce
qu'il puisse reprendre à la place où il
les a laissés le lendemain elle a été
réquisitionné pour héberger
l'officier a les mêmes alors quand il
erre entre qui s'est trouvée sur le pas
de la porte et a été surpris janot il a
vu ce sondage assis il s'est mis au
garde à vous et la criée il ya un autre
problème que posait et qui est celui du
jeu et de la liberté est-ce qu'en jouant
il se libère est-ce qu'ils évoluent
différemment est-ce qu'ils évoluent
librement
je ne pense pas je pense que le jeu fait
partie également d'un rituel qu'il est
très prisonnier de ses barrières qui
s'est érigé et auquel il s'accroche il
est prisonnier de ses baguettes de
tambour
il est prisonnier d'evry tu n'en veux
lutte qui l'écrit rythmiquement et
rituellement sur ses cahiers
guettez de vie la musique colle
intéresse énormément et il a énormément
le sens de la musique d'ailleurs il
saisit tous les airs vrai dit reid
le rythme s'est passé il ne fera pas le
samba pour une valse il sait très bien
que c'est donner un peu à tous les
enfants
ils ont vraiment le sens de la musique
c'est ce sont des enfants qu'on ne peut
pas laisser on ne peut pas se fier à eux
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce qui leur
passe par la tête
dans le temps il a eu un ennemi le feu
sous les vrais dingues il était jeune
mais à ce moment là alors vraiment
c'était beaucoup plus c'était beaucoup
plus désagréable que ce que ça l'est
maintenant puisque maintenant qui est
tout à fait il est raisonnable il faut
dire les choses comme elles sont les
résonnera le mais en fait je ne me
fierais pas calme m alors je le rappelle
il vous laissiez dubois et voulait faire
comme tout le monde
mon mari s'il est du bois alors lui
avait donné avec le planche sur une
chaise rhdp lui l'atout ciller la chaise
et la planche
côté acteurs vedettes alors là il est à
son affaire quand il peut ce succès lui
c'est lui qui parade c'est lui qui fait
le cirque c'est lui qui fait le le
comédien c'est lui qui joue c'est lui
qui chante
janot est acteur et spectateur à mon
avis ce qui commande c'est jouer c'est
se propulser et à partir du moment où il
existe par son action ça suffit à mon
avis le problème que pose le
développement intellectuel qu'il soit le
sien ou le nôtre c'est la critique
la critique c'est le moment nous ne
devenons pas schizophrène mais où nous
arrivons à faire cohabiter
l'acteur et le spectateur
[Musique]
en
la maman
[Musique]
il ya un problème de rythme qui se pose
c'est tout le monde nous avons à
l'intérieur de notre corps des rythmes
biologiques nous avons le vécu de notre
corps nous avons le rythme
da c'est un encore des nominations et en
france la chronobiologique tel est son
nom a été mise à l'honneur et bien série
on les retrouve dans le fonctionnement
de notre cerveau et dans le
fonctionnement de notre vie quotidienne
et c'est comme quand nous allons dans la
plage il faut le laisser faire tout
celle d'abord alors il entre dans l'eau
tout doucement avec le rmi portal il
faut pas pour cent il ne faut pas le
bousculer
il s'allonge et avec les mêmes ils
avancent quand il est rempli
complètement dans l'eau il avance et à
mesure il sort les bras et là
l'impression qu'ils nagent halak rôle
dans le temps de sauter au visage jouer
dans les fêtes de noël il ou elle et l'a
tué il a tué la poule est il de la lan
il a l'air il a la rage est vrai aussi
bien
déjà du temps compté deux parties n'a
jamais pas dans le document est une
pratique d'abord quelqu'un gesticuler
résulteront paris le pire est que là il
attendre le chat que nous avons mitsou
il vit que pour son mitsou et le jeune
carey ces gens l'embrassent avant ce
n'était pas ça ils n'étaient pas
habitués d'ailleurs là des convois y est
une bête hein chape qu'il fallait le
chasser avec une pierre et puis
maintenant alors mon dieu de garde si on
me faisait mal à son chat il ne voudrais
même pas qu'ils sortent dans la rue pour
ne pas le par le perdre en un mot c'est
une adoration
[Musique]
et
e
m
[Musique]
je
où
il se plaît énormément avec les enfants
et les enfants sont là jouent avec lui
de la même façon comme si c'était un
petit petit du même âge qui qui
participent à leur jeu est vraiment ou
pas qu'il est heureux et les enfants ont
pas de différence à nos maux
[Musique]
il aime énormément joué au ballon et il
joue bien quand même et par exemple un
match à la télévision ni suis ici il
sait très bien ce ce qui selon et alors
là le ballon pour lui oui c'est une
adoration
mais il a toujours joué un match amical
alors il gagna toujours le dos il arrive
c'est une phrase parce que d'abord il
chante il le chantait petit papa noël
chaque année ça se renouvelle et puis
ils attendent que le père noël apporte
les cadeaux comme tous les enfants et il
fait même sa lettre au père noël alors
voilà ils portent beaucoup de choses des
stylos et de cahier qui font partie de
des cadeaux du père noël
annie france savoie voilà c'est bien par
vous leur cahier avec les adultes
ce pari il a aussi énormément de
l'amitié on ne viennent même
certainement beaucoup de gens sont
viennent et ils sont attirés par lui
mais lui encore plus quand il sait que
quelqu'un doit venir et les lacs il
atteint il est heureux et tout sens
elles cotisent énormément avec lui son
repas d'anniversaire et il était heureux
parce qu'ils étaient étaient à bord et
de tout le monde qui lui a apporté tout
un tas de cadeaux l'avait lavé fêter il
était un homme ans il était le roi du
point de vue social c'est beaucoup une
affaire de cas particuliers
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas dire
qu'une famille va pouvoir garder un
enfant gobi en avance enfin ça dépend
beaucoup de son degré de mongolisme et
du degré de tolérance de la famille
il semble qu il
faudrait essayer de trouver un équilibre
entre la famille et l'école et beaucoup
d'établissements maintenant se rapproche
d'un idéal en proposant un internat
duquel les enfants sortent le samedi à
toulouse pour des vacances et acquérir
quand même un minimum de connaissances
scolaires tout en restant proche de leur
famille
maintenant on est confronté au problème
du mont joliens adultes et il faut
absolument envisager pour lui la
possibilité de s'insérer
professionnellement et dans la vie
exactement comme les autres humains
c'est-à-dire leur laisser la possibilité
d'avoir une vie sexuelle
d'autant que professionnel et ça pose le
problème des foyers il n'a pas encore
vraiment beaucoup de structures adaptées
parce qu on a surtout pensé au travail
n'est pas du tout à la vie le
vieillissement et herbes problème pippa
falloir aussi se pose elle autrement
puisque les parents disparaissant les
mongoliens agen l'an d'autres destinées
en ce moment que l'hôpital psychiatrique
quitter l'équipe était jusque là encore
c'est comme si on n'est pas adapté au
fait qu'ils sont quand même essentielle
affectueux et des humains exactement
comme les autres
mais vous voyez malgré ce malgré le
travail que ça me donne malgré la
contrainte
gilles m'a apporté beaucoup plus de joie
presque que de peine c'est le cas de
dire ma maison que du temps ne montrent
pas leur mari nous avions des visites
nous avions des amitiés c'était la
maison de la joie le la musique chanter
danser les gens venaient étaient attirés
ceux qui ne connaissent pas abel ceux
qui ne le connaissaient pas au premier
abord ça faisait bien un peu drôle mais
peu après c'était vite fini parce que
lui c'est lui qui s'avance c'est lui qui
attire
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'amitié que je n'aurai certainement à
lui s'il n'avait pas été lui est-ce
qu'il ne regrettait pas d'avoir pris
finalement événement où je ne le
regrette pas parce que le d'abord me
connaissez mon compagnon est de 20 j'ai
plus gris que ce que j'ai pleuré
certainement avec lui jeannot tels que
peut le voir est un média qui est
beaucoup de chance il a eu probablement
des chances génétique il a eu sans doute
des chances alimentaire il a dans sa vie
quotidienne des chances sociale et
familiale
[Musique]